excitedly awaiting the joining of
antonio i wonder antonio's gonna be like
hey guys i'm like hey man
i've had eric on for wait he never says
hey guys though
he always says hello everyone i don't
think he's gonna say that no
i don't think he's gonna i think that's
just a youtube thing you know
i thought that was his whole like brand
like he says it no matter what does he
say it like to a one person too
maybe i don't know you calling me
he doesn't say hello eric he'll say
hello everyone and you're just like dude
it's just me and he's like i know but i
i have to
okay so you guys call him antonio or is
it more polite to call him a god notor
we call him antonio and tony oh okay
not antonio the same way as wait what
what
so there's antonio but there's also
antonio like
eric we're we're three americans we say
antonio
wait i've never heard anybody call
somebody antonio what
i thought was the same way like kasparov
versus kasparov
no
this is gonna be a fun show i'm excited
i'm really confused i've never heard
anybody ever say antonio it's always
antonio
i think eric has just traveled a lot
um and what language is it on tony i
just thought like when you go to europe
the a's are pronounced as ah
rather than i think he's i think like
actually he's correct
in italy it's still it's still antonio
really oh
at least again i've never been to italy
so
i'm learning something new but okay
that's fine it's just like as we all say
it's san
antonio in in texas
chad i actually speak italian so i i am
familiar with it but i i know it's
it's antonio it's not on it's ann
antonio
wait but how how do you say a god mature
do you say a good mater
i think we say a gad mature yeah it's
agate mater is how qiu pronounces it
ah which is i don't i don't even know
anymore which is probably
not correct but i don't know
okay
probably not but apparently they're
saying that's not how you pronounce it
at croatian so ah and croatia ah
croatian maybe it's ah
ah and croatian is antonio okay croatian
okay that makes sense
so again guys it's uh eric rosen and
myself
versus the two grand masters antonio and
hicaro
so sweet did we clear this up also on
antonio i don't think we've formally met
so nice to meet you oh likewise eric
likewise
but i feel like like we've known each
other for ages so i actually saw you in
real life
from a distance
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh the world championship
match and it was super crowded
and there were a lot of people in this
like small space and you were like all
the way
at the end of the hall and then i was
going to say hi
but then you you disappeared into the
vip lounge
i wasn't a vip so that's kind of sad
uh that you weren't a vip or that we
didn't meet
uh both okay not not to interrupt this
incredibly
uh adorable uh moment but um guys just a
friendly reminder that the admins of
just four player chess will be doing the
matches for us but the top left
only accept an invite from somebody
named gdii
if it's not that person most likely your
computer will be hacked and all your
money will be taken from you
oh yeah they already invited me i
declined sorry i declined it too
so folks please do not harass us when we
have a
pre-planned programming do not we are
not going to play you
we will have games beginning for the
four of us um
so anyway please continue uh eric what
happened after antonio went to the vip
lounge
i never saw him again i guess i'm still
not out
so terrifying experience my god
i would invite eric to any vip lounge
that i had
eric have you been in any of the have
you since you've traveled a lot too have
you been in any of the uh like really
cool uh like airline at like the airport
in the airline lounges
yeah so i mean i traveled through
singapore a lot
and whenever i'm in asia i make an
effort just to stop in
the the giant marina bay sands top floor
infinity pool yeah well i i haven't been
to the infinity pool
i've i've been to multiple airline
lounges in in
the changi airport good man and i always
make an effort to make the layover as
long as possible
and usually if i there's usually like a
two or three hour
limit but if i overstay it usually they
don't kick me out
so it's nice oh by the way so
the other big question of ours how do we
pronounce your first name
ah oh it's actually antonio oh it is
okay okay
that's right yeah antonio
antonio what about your
uh your youtube channel name
oh that's uh agad mator ah
okay i don't think uh any of you got
that one right
for several years like i referred to you
as agonator
oh no but that's that's gross no no
i i'm learning though so i always said i
gotta call you
do we call you by your your real name or
your youtube channel name
oh i i think the real name will do
antonio okay
yeah but but if you if you want you can
call me like
captain hook he doesn't really
[Laughter]
i mean is that because you look like him
or just like we're calling you any name
uh i don't know if it if it pleases eric
i guess
you know it's it's sort of being sorry
for not meeting him in london
i'm still disappointed but it's okay
oh game time i feel like not playing
four player chess is more relaxing
than playing four-player chess
all right so it's uh what is it bullet
no it's 115. oh okay
okay oh it's a straight bullet no no
it's 1 15.
are we playing teams are we free-for-all
this is free-for-all we're starting
oh right so i'm the best player so i
need to start my dominance so we need to
change
against hikaru of course
no against levi is actually the best
player here he's put more time into the
game than i ever have
in free for all i think i think you're
you're stronger
oh love you stop trying to pretend look
at that you know
okay wait do i queen uh when i hit
eighth rank yeah yeah it's where you see
that weird like that weird thing that
looks like it doesn't belong
like your screen is dirty but it isn't
uh but i don't
know dude that's not a good move
but in are we still playing teams or
free-for-all free-for-all
okay it says so okay i was hoping you
weren't gonna do that because
now we're nerfing each other levy but
this is free for all
yeah but you're supposed to keep all
your pieces not damaging me
okay it's fine they need some they need
some mods anyway so
but this isn't teams levy why do you
keep talking about it's like it's odds
i okay you don't you you
okay i mean i mean okay i mean whatever
you know
okay yeah because you damaged your own
dark squares when you did that
but whatever okay okay love you then
don't offer the exchange in the first
place push your pawn up to
to like to g3 can we just acknowledge
the fact that eric rosen said he doesn't
know anything about four players just
he's 1989.
true i'm still trying to crop you guys
okay
also i have no idea what i'm doing levy
was teaching me the other day
and then you know what okay right i'm
gonna do something i'm gonna do
something nice for the audience
i'm gonna play from hikaru's perspective
oh wait no i can't even do that because
the camera's wrong
it's okay it's all good but see and
antonio's just getting a queen here no
can't do that
it's okay if he gets a queen he's gonna
lose both
okay i love you i like your confidence
oh listen i had to get in on the trash
talking
see you in the vip lounge
[Laughter]
okay uh i'm going for another queen i
guess
seems like a reasonable plan i feel like
we're all getting crushed by
antonio right i think we all have so
much material
yeah well not not yet if he gets another
queen then we're in trouble yeah
i'm gonna try and get all of them
well evie why are you trying to be
annoying i'm just blocking you
out man i'm just you know yeah but he's
you're preventing me from ever being
able to attack antonio and get a get a
queen
but you're not even supposed to attack
your opposite
sorry what like you're opposite blue and
green and you're supposed to like
beat not attacking but he's just making
another queen nah
no he don't make he's not gonna win
okay levy i think it's unstoppable
yeah it's actually kind of hard to stop
because of where our pawns are
like eric's the only one who can cite it
i can do something it's up to eric
oh that's a nice one that's a nice one
eric nice one
i might even give up the queen to grab
your knight
that's exactly what i'm gonna do what
oh oh because you're worth one point oh
oh oh oh but oh but lovey is a nice move
as do i oh there you go
yeah i i i think i'm gonna i'm gonna
play this so
because i want to be
can you annoying you draw arrows even
like in two-player mode
yeah just nobody else sees it i think
mm-hmm picks up your audience
uh okay okay so both of you guys are
coming after my queen okay
now i'm just confused do i take the
queen
i guess i do yeah because now if i
recapture he grabs me
either of you want to recapture right
um i guess that's
that's how how we're going to do it four
player chests is a type of chest played
by four players
all right let's just move this away
you i mean you saw that i was attacking
but now he gets a queen you could have
stopped him by putting the queen on like
on on j time j9 i'm sorry
well i was assuming eric would stop him
from making a queen how can eric stop
him
i just want to save
no i thought bishop checkered something
yeah but it still doesn't stop oh i see
okay
yeah there we go somehow this turned
into something that's not
fantastic all right so third queen oh
yeah
okay but two one already is gone so
we'll just have to do the same thing to
this queen okay i
i'm really scared of where my queen is
though i'm not gonna lie
i don't understand why you put it there
no he should put it up one story should
put it he should have put it to j9 just
one square back and then he would have
been able to take the pawn
you lower rated guys even though i'm the
second lowest rated don't understand
what's
going on here you just you don't
understand
okay that's a nice check thank you
uh let's do this again what
oh oh because it's five for one that's
actually a good move that's good oh yeah
you're very clever guy
how many points is it for a win it's
like 25 or something
i guess what do you mean like checkmate
win or just winning the game no no
just if you like move back and forth and
grab a couple of pieces
oh no but but it's uh bishops are worth
five
i think rooks are worth five and then
queens are worth nine unless it's a
promoted queen in which case it's worth
one
uh yeah it all depends free-for-all can
either be a nine or a one-point game
so okay
that's that's a nice pawn move thank you
uh all right so i will i will grab this
definitely no
all right no loudly exclaimed
eric at least some points for me
but that that was your like your your
newly reborn queen
yeah hikaru and i are just casually
trading bishops farming points for each
other
okay uh we can do something like uh
something are you gonna make another
queen now uh
he's a really nasty move here he is a
really he's a really nice yeah see if
you were if
you were if you were a toxic participant
of the show you
yeah i completely forgot about that i'm
in check so if you had attacked my queen
with anything you would have won my
queen
well maybe not because hikara would have
defended or one of them would have
defended so it's not
so easy yeah yeah why would i be your
queen lovey this is free-for-all
no because you know antonio's going to
take and then you'll take oh yeah yeah
yeah
you take five points so it's not true
that's true that's true
so is there a mode that is
where you only play for checkmate where
you don't grab points
no it's part of the game it's like uh
it's like quidditch you know you can
score in the right i
play a lot of footage so and and
have fun yeah
so uh what does your shirt say antonio
oh it's uh my sister got me this it says
the best sister in the world
uh i have the best sister in the world
okay i thought it's
the shirt was calling you the best
sister no i don't know
[Laughter]
she said i had to wear it on the stream
oh nice
alright
wait i thought it was a bad strategy to
castle
i mean i don't really i don't really
have a choice because levy's just trying
to attack me
oh that pawn is really going places
i'm trying i'm learning from your
strategies
i'm gonna try and improve and not lose
the queen once i get it
okay ah that makes sense yeah
some nice four player chest prophylaxis
okay let's um let's just tap the and
have some fun okay
oh wait a second can i
no you can't do anything levy but nice
try
well you were thinking like queen
capture spawn in front of king yeah
no that no but i i think if i take his
pawn over
there by his rook it's like okay but i
just went up on it might be too
dangerous
okay you're going to lose levy don't you
want to finish in the top two
i'm going to okay
[Music]
because levy you get crippled then you
you [ __ ] yourself you have no chance
if you [ __ ] me then there's no
way you're gonna have a chance well if i
played queen takes
all the way pawn near your rook right
and i move my king and then you just
trade the queens though no no i was just
gonna go back
i was gonna run backwards oh you were
just gonna take the one pawn really yeah
yeah i'm i mean okay that's weird well i
didn't do it
that's really weird man for one pawn
that's really weird
but i didn't even do it i used four
player chests one point and this
position wouldn't matter
like at all listen you're not uh well i
bro can we just acknowledge the fact
that i did not play it
sure sure okay sure thank you um i'm
gonna do it now
just uh okay let's go
what is what isn't what does antonio
want oh he just didn't want to lose a
pawn okay let's go here
yeah it's uh i like that one
oh okay trying to activate some pieces
i feel trend well you you checked me
that wasn't very nice so i
i feel like i need to attack you now i
just celebrated by stealing lacroix on
the floor
um i think it's not near my computer or
else two streams go down at the same
time
you have to borrow those bounty paper
towels from hikaru
i literally i literally have that no
joke
yeah that's good awesome too just in
case
not a sponsored stream
uh doing levy
ah you're trying to bring your rook in
that's what you're trying to do
no well antonio also had a fork like
seven moves in a row with his knife
that's right yeah but early lose the
game here
well not no knights knight for rook is a
really good trade bishop for rook is
so so yeah but not with four players
still in the game you want to
keep everything as long as possible true
that's what they taught me in four
player chess academy wait then why why
did you sack your queens for my minor
pieces
because it was a second queen so it's
good
yeah cause it's only worth one yeah it's
probably it is the right choice
um yeah this guy is doing nothing here
um
who do i attack
everyone's like very salido i'm just
placing my knight there
i'm not gonna capture your queen oh
oh okay i mean if you say so no no it's
totally fine okay then that allows me
the luxury to come up with a plan
somewhere
no i don't believe you
wait because we're across from each
other we should work together right
i already i i don't i don't understand
so i'm just gonna go here
okay
um everything's attacking my knight
oh that's right actually oh yeah i
didn't even see that
yeah a lot of action on that night
just make a pawn chain oh
blocking my bishop very nice very nice
[Music]
so this is always good oh
thank thank antonio's been missing so
many chances to just absolutely
embarrass me
like where knight takes pawn check and
hikaru wins my queen but i mean if it
it's only
i mean that that just takes me out of
the game but it yeah
it only that doesn't help me really
because you don't you you hikaru is
still around is what you're saying
yeah this way i i just keep keep low
and uh good stuff i like what eric is
doing though he's very quiet he's just
very quiet and like
being defensive i'm just trying to lay
low and not get smashed and
very secretive i mean everyone's
attacking me from like all these
different directions
that's true yeah i don't know what i'm
doing so
let me try to up a little
hmm
i just thought it was a nice weird
square to place the bishop
it's a nice diagonal every every
everyone yeah is good
oh that's weird that's fast
um
what what now
moves moves moves moves
that is an interesting move wow
yeah could be
oh really no because i think i was in
some
trouble if i didn't do that but i i have
no understanding of this game so
am i accepting uh am i accepting song
requests now
like like right now on a no song stream
yeah
you can request you won't get it but you
can request it
that was a a very nice attempt
okay
sort of trading queens but also going
for checkmate
no no no
what trying to check mate unbelievable
eric just casually i'm just gonna go for
my
my connect four pawn chain
why is antonio not taking my pieces
well i'm hoping to keep it cramped so
hikaru can checkmate you or something
okay
all right um because
yeah okay
it's interesting
yo this guy is like a tactician god
okay nice check
[Music]
all right and now we push
i think is there a move here no there
isn't
you are a little lucky why
uh uh
well why am i lucky i don't understand
well i can't say anything you have to
figure out why you're lucky
i feel like levy understands this game
much deeper than all of us
no i mean i just i sometimes you see
tactics that's that's literally it
you go after my bishop that's that's
gonna dm you that's cool
i dm'd you on discord ah okay wait so
i'm lucky no wait why am i lucky because
cause if because if that happened that
would have been that would have been
like it would have been he would have
stole is what i'm saying
i'm but i'm not checkmating you anyway
[Music]
where do i move got him
actually maybe you should flag oh hikara
wants to maybe
wait is there an hassan in this game yep
if i so if i move two
he can take me
someone in my chat just said wait hi
caro has discord
yes i have discord disconnect from
reality i suppose but
um very very hard to follow all the
diagonals
uh-huh and the files this i feel like
this is a very
high level game oh yeah like
super high level superhero definitely
no idea what's happening there wait so
if i move my rook pawn up too
he can
or not i don't know actually can i or
not
just just to see don't do it i think i
can
yeah i think i can it doesn't it lets me
make the preview because that's a
sideways on passang that's not like a
real
but the pawns on a5 it's like a5
captures v6
i think okay you guys should just attack
akaro so he can't
on pass on me but eric you're you're
trying to win you've got a ton of pieces
thank you for that lovey thank you i'm
just literally
[Music]
nice yeah that's a that's a that's a
good move
but yeah the guys to the to the left of
you has the position
so if they attack you then
okay so whatever happening here
so many pawns for eric you will be
unstoppable
that's a nice trick
a very nice trick
okay and eric's margin is falling down
the center of the board
i think like eric's got the best
strategy i feel like he's gonna win
he just has yeah because you decided to
attack me lovey
you hey who took you you don't exactly
eric doesn't have any chance but now
like now we're both dead
no wait well antonio's doing us all a
favor
definitely has the same as king
uh yeah for now but uh hikaru has a
second queen you're getting a second
queen
um
that was a good move not not the
greatest
okay so you got it
pretty good pretty good there's six
queens on the board
uh too many too many yeah six on the
board
okay
okay very safe square for the king
it's honestly i don't think it's a safe
square
i'm not feeling that safe no it's
definitely not safe
okay i think it's good though because if
i'm only near antonio
then he goes and then i go next so i
feel like
but no it's it's definitely not safe but
i have a i have a very interesting move
that
could be good but it's not
what is that
i just really wanted to put my queen in
the center okay
very aesthetic
what is the idea here you don't get it i
also don't get it no one gets it i have
two seconds
so
um
all right that's not happening
from finland love from new york to
finland
what oh i thought i thought you wanted
me to capture hikaru's roof
okay sorry lovey lovey you're such a bad
person
like you you conned him that central
queen really paid off
i i don't think i conned anyone i think
he just moved his bishop there
yeah but they did it to help you to get
rid of hikaru's rook
right or something like that
oh or something like that
ah dude i don't i just saw a free piece
so i decided to
yeah with two seconds it does make sense
oh that was nice
thank you you guys are you guys are
feeding me free stuff i like it
that was actually very nice
well you know you can do that like if
you if you're in in between two players
you can
play a move and then like
uh there's a don't do it
don't do it it's actually probably a
very bad move
[Music]
if it was the other one i'd i'd probably
do it but not this one
the fake one
oh levy you're trying to set up a
checkmate
i am yeah yeah
if uh oh nice
so yeah that's not gonna work what's in
that
water in croatia what checkmate am i
trying to set up and on who
uh well my knight guards the bishop and
uh eric has a
mate set up on my bishop and if you
capture the knight that's
uh that would be it wouldn't it
that's actually a really nice plan yeah
what how did you even well then i would
be
wait you're gonna flag oh oh oh
yeah i was i was worrying about that for
too long
no dude you just straight up told me a
plan that i didn't even see i mean
my goodness i'm just capturing free
pieces
and now i'm almost flagged yeah like
levy somehow you're like somehow winning
now
no i'm no way i'm i'm lost
there's no way i can
no but it doesn't make any sense i don't
have any pieces like
yeah but you have a very active queen
that's
yeah you do have an active queen i feel
like you guys could have punished that
though like hikaru's got a freaking
artillery
of stuff not exactly let me stop stop
acting like i do
i don't have that many pieces either
sort of oh two queens is not enough
how am i getting a third queen when eric
is about to make a queen also
i i don't know queens
and then enjoy life
yeah now everyone is getting a queen
that's sad
it's like they're what like nine queens
on the board almost it's not for you but
it's happy for us
it's actually insane this is actually
insane
whatever what is that what are you doing
what are you doing what is that
i'm blocking your queens obviously
that's not a queen lovey it's two
squares
you need better glasses do you not see
that little speck on your on your uh
chess board uh the queening square is
two
uh two up not one no i'm i'm i'm
blocking your blue queen which is a
queen
that is oh oh oh that's what you meant
oh i thought you know that i'm like
promoting okay
no no i'm just trying to get your blue
queens away from me
okay that's what i'm doing hmm
that's not actually what you're doing
oh my god oh what i can't help myself
oh my what do i what is no one
controlling that
i don't even want to trade a pawn for
one of his queens
oh i'm i'm in trouble levy why are you
doing this
i couldn't trade queens man i couldn't
trade queens
this is so crazy this is eric's first
ever game on stream and he has four
queens oh oh oh that's a four
oh a kind that was that was not good
because now i think eric can just mate
me
how many points is uh uh like a royal
fork
can i recommend me i don't think i want
to meet you though
mate america made him 20 it's 20 points
for the mate but remember if you check
me and antonio checks me
and mates me he gets the 20 points so
just
just do it eric i don't want to do it
just do it
what what is that pot twist
uh my pawn is not moving what
it's not carried by my knife eric that
was not a good move on your part dude oh
you really messed that up dude yeah
because i made it
now because you you i told you not to
give a check
yeah but you should you should not have
let him lose why
he was a threat he's a highest rated
i don't yeah but i don't know the most
points is what i mean like
yeah oh and that's also mate so now what
it's
me versus eric's queens exactly oh well
i mean
yeah i mean oh eric still wins he still
is going to win probably
but yeah with a million million queens
there's so many queens eric this is
gonna just get worse we don't have
we're a team and it's yeah you could
just wait
we were a team no yeah yeah no i'm sure
what
no no no i meant like oh we're gonna
play teams so you can just
trade every everything for everything i
mean a queen for a pawn basically
let's see
yeah of course this is a four-player
immortal
yeah it seems so oh no
coming from behind
what does this move oh that pawn is
pinned
eric is disgusting at this game this is
what is this eric
oh thank you that's just terrible that's
just terrible
how does this man have four queens yeah
i don't know
we allowed following antonio's opening
all right by the way eric you know you
can claim wins right really oh i didn't
know that
yeah if i had to take me to get enough
points
but where does it say claim win oh
you're right because i was down
i was down points you're right my bad
yeah you couldn't climb
you couldn't that was pretty pretty
intense i feel so accomplished